If everybody would just try to
understand each other.
And by the way, I put myself in that
category, too, you know, try to
understand these people that I make fun
of or castigate or whatever.
We if we all did it a little more, it
would help us because what a horrible
place we're in now.
You know, we can't agree on anything.
What you just.
Did is what I'm talking about.
Like, that's that's what I mean.
I witnessed you do on your show.
It's not that the things that you're
saying are so profound.
You're simplifying a feeling and you're
trying to just simply paint a picture
to your audience to make your audience
see. Different perspectives and
different sides. To me, it has come off
heartfelt, it's come off courageous,
and I think it's dope as hell that you
used that platform to do so, knowing
that the consequences could be, you
know, divisive, ratings, etcetera.
And by the way, I do feel like I should
say, like I do feel like a lot of my
colleagues in late night are do the
same thing and do it really well.
And, you know, I do feel like one of
the things that helps keep me sane when
you see all these terrible things
happening is knowing that I can then go
on TV and say, Hey, this is not right
and maybe we should do this.
And I do think that for me and for my
wife says the same thing, you know,
it's like it's it's it's an outlet to
be able to speak about this stuff.
You just got finished talking about your
colleagues, the relationships between
the guys of late night today.
How are they? Are you guys is there an
amazing synergy that you guys had?
Is there a relationship between you?
I despise them all, No, Um I know it's
boring, but I really like every one of
those guys. Why do you think it's
boring?
It's not. I think people to hear.
Fun when people fight, but I think
there's also a really different reason
why we. We aren't, as at each other's
throats as Jay and Dave were.
And I think it's because everything is
splintered now. And so and because also
people watch our shows on YouTube
mostly. It's not like you have to
choose, you know, in the old days, you
just like, all right, I have to watch
either David Letterman or Jay Leno.
And, you know, they're both on at 11:30
and I'm going to have to pick one of
them. And it's not like that now.
Like, in fact, a lot of people will sit
there and they watch our show, the
monologue and Colbert and Seth Meyers
and Jimmy Fallon and James Gordon, you
know, and they watch all this stuff
because they just like late night
television.
I like that. I mean, more importantly, I
just like that you can say that people
need to hear it because it's not the
times of old.
And also, I love talking to those guys
because there were only like eight
people that have our job.
You know, like I went to dinner one
night with Seth Meyers and we just we
talked for like four hours straight.
And one of the best conversations I've
ever had because we just motored
through all of it.
Seth is a good dude, though.
Yeah, I like Seth a lot.
Do you guys share guests?
Hey, man, you don't want to get X, Y
and Z? Oh, pulling teeth.
Oh, God. Hey, have you had that happen?
Don't do it. Don't do it.
It's not the best.
I'm telling you now.
It's less of a warning usually, and more
of a commiseration.
You know, like we've already both
experienced it.
There are definitely.
There's definitely that for sure.